[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج من
المصدر المهتم بتحليل مشهد الاعلامي
العربي والدولي
حراره الحرب العالميه بين روسيا والغير
سقوط الخطاب الاعلامي لحكومه رئيس
غلطه صحفيه كادت ان تشعل حربا عالميا
ثالثا ما خلفيه قصه وكاله اسوسيه بريس عن
استهداف في روسيا لي بولندا العضو الذكري
او اوروبا القارس يدخل في قلب
الاستراتيجيات الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
كل طرف يستخدمه عامل الطبيعه هذا في الحرب
النفسيه الاعلاميه ضد الاخر فمسم الشتاء
هذا العام ينقضوا على الاوروبيين باسعار
الغاز هي الاعلى بسته اضعاف من المتوسطها
في روسيا تهدد باغلاق اخر خط انابيب يتصل
باوروبا ورقه الضغط تلك الصفه الاعلام
الروسيه باستخدامها مرددا عباره رعب البرد
في ماده القوات الروسيه هجوما على البنيه
التحتيه
[موسيقى]
في ما يتعلق بحمله رعبا من البرد والضربات
التي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه انظر الى
الضجه التي اثارها وطريقه رد فعلهم ما
يؤكد اننا قمنا بالامر الصحيح
دون غاز او كهرباء او اي شيء اخر وبسبب ان
النظام كيف اختار طريقه مجرميه الحرب
ان يؤثر في قبليه الدوله
الصناعه توقفت وهذا هو اهم شيء تلك
الصناعه التي نمت جلاله الاموال الان نركز
على الحق الضاره بنظام الطاقه كلها سنن
ذلك
فلوس يبدو انها ترى في فصل الشتاء فرصه
لزياده الضغط ليس فقط على اوكرانيا بل
خلفائها ايضا بذلك استخدم روت الطاقه
كسلاح وفقائقا قبل الحرب كانت روسيا توفر
40 الى 50% من واردات الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الغاز الطبيعي قبل ان يغلق فوتين خط
الانابيب الرئيسي الى اوروبا لترتفع اسعار
الوقود 80% عن عام 2019 و 2020 للضغط على
الاقتصادات الاوروبيه
المشكله ليست مرتبطه فقط بالاقتصاد اسعار
الكهرباء الحاليه ستؤدي الى ارتفاع معدل
الوفيات الى اعلى من المتوسط التاريخي في
فصل الشتاء رغم انه جاء معتدلا في اوروبا
عموما وفي اوكرانيا تحديدا قد يتجاوز عدد
القتلى جراء البرد بفعل السلاح الطاقه
المستخدم من قبل بوتين عدد الجنود الذين
لقوا حذفهم في ساعات القتال وفقا
مع زياده الضغط النفطيا تاتي زياده الرئيس
الفرنسي الى واشنطن في هذا السياق لطلب
المساعده من امريكا على المستوى النفطي
بعد ان شك لهذا الملف بوادر الانشقاقات
العميقه بين الاوروبيين واشنطن الفتره
الماضيه فكان الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشعر
الالماني قد هدد سابقا بالانتقام التجاري
من امريكا
من الوقود الى اوروبا كما جاء هنا
في المقابل قد يكون الروز داخل روسيا
الاتحاديه بمنع عن صقيع الشتاء ولكن في
ساحات الحرب النقص اللوجستي ادى الى دحر
جنودروس كما اكدت فورز عبر هذه الصور نرى
هنا الجنود الروس بالكاد يتحركون لحمايه
انفسهم من القنابل بسبب البرد الشديد
وابقى فورس فان الخنادق الروسيه ليست
مجهزه بالشكل المطلوب لمواجهتي الصقيع
وبالنسبه الى الباحثه في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات ايفانا الاواني حمله
سيكولوجيه معاكسه ضد روسيا واقترحت في
مقال راي في بوليتكو تقليبه الراي العام
على بوتين عبر كشف ما تنعم روسيه جرى
ارتفاع اسعار النفط فيما الجنود روسيا
ارزحون تحت شبح الموت والهلا
هذه الرساله يجب ان تصل الى الروس فابان
الحرب البارده كانت لاذاعات الامريكيه كا
صوت امريكا اوروبا الحره والراديو الحريه
تشكل القاصره لنقل وجهه النظر الامريكيه
للشعب الروسي اما اليوم فيجب التحايل على
الحظر الروسي عبر التطبيقات الفي بي ان
لتكثيف الحملات الاعلاميه ضد بوتين
والكرملين
حتى الان بفعل الاعلام
فان النزعه القوميه مرتفعه في روسيا
75% من الروس ينظرون الى امريكا نظره
سلبيه وفقه
وتنضموا الينا من امريكا الكاتبه ايفانا
ستريتر الباحثه في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه اذا كيف يمكن ان تؤثر الحلبي
السيكولوجيه المضاده التي تتحدثين عنها في
احداث تغيير في المزاج العام في روسيا بعد
في ظل هذا يعني النزعه القوميه الكبيره في
روسيا الان
اهلا بك
[موسيقى]
شكرا لاضافه هذه الليله انت محققه تماما
مشاعر القوميه عاليه جدا جدا من الجانب
الروسي والسؤال الحقيقي هو كيف يمكن الغرب
ان يستخدمه العمليات الاعلاميه للتاثير في
القلوب والعقول داخل روسيا
مع تصاعدي القوميه سيكون من الصعب جدا
الامر ايام الحرب البارده
في الواقع من سمعه روسيا العظمى وفي
الحقيقه فان الناس داخل روسيا لا ينظرون
بعين رضا للحرب في اوكرانيا ليس بسبب ان
اوكرانيا تعني لهم
وانما بسبب ان بوتين حتى من عظمه روسيا
ومن سمعتهم لذلك من المهم ايضا للغرب ان
يواجهها سلبيات روسيا الاعلاميه
والاتصاليه في الغرب وافضل وسيله للدفاع
في الحقيقه هي الهجوم وما يتعين على
الغربي فعله بالحقيقه هو استهداف وسلبيات
الروسيه داخل الروسيه نفسها والقولون
السكان والامهات الروسيات ان اعزاؤهم جار
ارسالهم وقودا للحرب الانفراليه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا
كما ان ما يتعين علينا فعله ايضا ان يقول
لقتها بشان السرديه الروسيه مثل ربط كل
التاريخ بالاستعمار واحداث استقطاب ضد
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده كما
يتعين علينا واعتقد انه سيكون الاسلوب
الافضل لمجابهه السرديه الروسيه هو
استخدام السخريه والدعابه لانهم فعلا
ليستطيعون الرد على ذلك عبر هذا الاسلوب
وهو فعلا من افضل الاسلحه التي يمكن ان
نستخدمها لمواجهه عمليات التاثير الروسيه
الاعلام الاوكرانيه والاوروبيه المضاده
ضرر الاوكرانيين الفقيع الشتاء بعد تلقي
شياب ضربات الموجعه في بنيتها التحديات
ويقلد
جدا ودعيني اقولها بشكل صريح ومباشر نحن
في وقت المتاخر فنحن لم ننظم اي عمليه
تاثير منذ اعوام عديده جدا في المقابل في
ايامنا هذه يمكننا ان ننفذ عمليات
الاعلاميه واتصاليه لقول الحقيقه بشان حرب
بوتين في الاماكن الاخرى لان بوتا ليس
بصدد استهداف الرؤوس داخل روسيا عبر
التضيقي على الاعلام وحظر المواقع
الاخباريه الغربيه مثلا ولكن بوتين بصدد
استهداف الغرب ايضا في المناطق الاخرى مثل
اسيا وافريقيا وانت محققه تماما بالاشاره
الى الحرب واستمرارها خلال الشتاء حيث
سيكون الامر صعبا لذلك نحن بحاجه الى
استخدام الفضاء الاعلاميه لقول الحقيقه في
الغرب وشرح اسباب صواب دعم اوكرانيا
واهميه توفير السلاح الاوكرانيا وغيرها
مما تحتاجه للنصر لا يوجد احد يحب الحروب
غير المنتهيه ولكن حتى تحقق اوكرانيا
النصره يتعين علينا التحرك بسرعه
وليس ذلك فقط بل ايضا الاشاره اليكم هو
امر مثير للانشغال في افريقيا بازمه
الغذاء والاضطراب الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
واتصاليه لحمايه افريقيا من حملات التظليل
الروسيه لان روسيا بصدد فرض حاله استقطاب
وايضا لان روسيا تنحى بالائمه في ازمه
الغذاء على الغرب هناك
المونديال رغم تهديدات النظام الايراني
كيف اسقطت المعارضه خبطته لاستخدام
المونديال صالح خطابه الاعلامي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
تحول الى ساحه لتبادل الرسائل الاعلاميه
وخاصه خلال المباراه التي جمعت بين ايران
وامريكا بالنسبه الى النظام الايراني
المونديال يمثل كل شيء الا مناسبه رياضيه
ترفيهيه حيث حاولت السلطات بشتى الطرق
استغلال الاضواء الاعلام الدولي للحدث
للترويجي لرواياته عن الاحداث بعد ان فشل
بتصويقها في الاعلام الدولي وحتى المحليه
ولكن المعارضين نظام كانوا بالمرصاد كل
دعاياته اسمها امي وشعارات المعارضه فقط
على
المدرجات رغم كل الضغوط
تسلل النظام الى المدرجات عبر نشر عناصره
من البرسيج والقوى الامنيه لمحاوله اظهار
دعم الجماهير للسياسات السلطات في طهران
ولكن الناشطين الرصد عناصر النظام وكشفوهم
عبر مواقع التواصل وحاول عناصر النظام
الظهور في الاعلام لترديد الروايه التي
يتمسك بها المسؤولون الايرانيون ولكن
المعارضين كان كانوا لهم في المرصد
ايران
في ايران للايرانيين للنساء حقوق متساويه
مع الرجال لنا جميعا حقوق متساويه في كل
المنظمات جميعنا متساوون
انها تكذب انها تكذب
لا اعرف من هو غير صحيح لانه هناك من يريد
احداث فتنه بين بعضنا البعض
مع منتخب امريكا واعتبر ان ايران تقارع
بذلك النظام الراسمالي الامريكي كما قالت
صحيفه كيهان التابعه للحرس الثوري وكشفت
السي ان ان النظام هدد عائلات لاعب
المنتخب الايراني بالسجن والتعذيب اذا
اساء اللاعبون التصرف في المباراه ضد
امريكا
الايرانيين الذين لا يسمح لهم بالاختلاط
خارج الفريق او لقاء الاجانب
بذلك لعب المنتخب تحت رايه النظام وبذلك
اعتبر المعارضون ان هذا المنتخب لا يمثل
الايرانيين ولد تسجيل امريكا هدفها انطلقت
الاعين الناريه فرحا في عده مدن ايرانيه
كما نقلت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وراينا
فرح الايرانيين في الشوارع لخساره منتخب
النظام مرددين هتافات الموت للديكتاتور
وتعالى اصواتهم بالزغاريت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بذلك كل سرديه النظام التي حاول زرعها على
مر السنوات في معادلات امريكا واعتبارها
الشيطان الاكبر بغيه تبذير وجوده وتبرير
سياساته العدوانيه سقطت على ارض الملعب
فتعانق الفريقان بروح رياضيه بعد نهايه
المباراه
مشاهد فرح الايرانيين بخساره المنتخب صوره
فرحهم بفوز المنتخب ضد امريكا عام 198
وبين الامس واليوم صوره النظام تغيرت وليس
فقط في اذهان الايرانيه
بل ايضا في بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
التي توصف باللبراليه والتي تتناغم في بعض
الاحيان مع خطاب النظام وكانت حتى الامس
القريب مقتنعه بروايه النظام عن
ديمقراطياته وشعبيته لكن مفارقه فرح
الايرانيين بفوز خصومهم الامريكيين
استوقفت الجامعه
اذا
النظام كان وراء فرحه اليدين بخساره
منتخبهم الذي يعد اداه للتنميه
سوء تفاهم لمده عشر دقائق على منصه داخليه
لوكاله اساسيه بين صحفيين الوكاله الانباء
ادى الى انتشار معلومه خاطئه المعلومه
جعلت تصعيد التوتر الدوليه يبلغ اعلى
مستوياتهم منذ ازمه الصواريخ القويه في
ذروه الحرب البارده بين حلف الناتجه
وروسيا من جهه اخرى موقع سما فور نشر
خلفيات سوء التفاهم في الوكاله ما ادى الى
طرد المسؤول على التقرير الذي كاد ان
يتسبب في حرب عالميه الثالثه
القصه بدات يوم الثلاثاء في 15 نوفمبر
عندما نشرت وكاله واسشات بريس عاجلا يقول
ان مسؤول استخباراتيا امريكيا اكد ان
صواريخ روسيه سقطت في بولندا العضو في حلف
شمال الاطلسي ما اسفر عن مقتل شخصين
الوكاله ارفقت العاجل بالاشاره الى ان
القاده في بولندا عقده اجتماعا طارئا بسبب
الوضع المتازم
سارع الفنتجون للتعليق على خبر وكاله
الانباء من دون تاكيد الخبر
وي ار ورديه
مفاداتنا الى هناك ناديه البلبيسي كانت
حاضرا عندما رصدت اجواء التوتر الشديد
التي دفعت بالرئيس الامريكي الى تاجير
حضور مناسبه لدعم جهود البيئه واجتمع مع
قاده حلف الناتو في اجتماع طارق للتاكدي
من المعلومه واتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه
على ضوئها هذا قبل ان يعود الرئيس بيضا
وينفي الخبر مؤكدا انه من المستبعاد ان
تكون روسيا وراء سقوط الصاروخان في بولندا
فيما تراجعت وكاله الساشات بريس عن
التقرير وصححات المعلومه كما نرى هنا
وفصلت مراسل الامن القومي في الوكاله الذي
ارسل الخبر والذي كان قد انضم اليها قبل
سنتين
لكن المراسلات الداخليه في الوكاله تظهر
جانبا اخر من القصه سوء تفاهم واضح ليس
وحده المراسل مسؤول عنه اللغط حصل عندما
ارفق المراسل خبر بمصدر مسؤول استخبارات
يقول ان نائب رئيس قسم التحقيقات الصحفيه
في الوكاله يطق به ولكن المراسل لم يحدد
ما اذا كان الخبر هو الذي مؤكد من قبل
نائب رئيس التحقيقات ام ان فقط المصدر يثق
به نائب الرئيس فعندما طلب من المراسل
كتابه القصه اعتذر كما قال هنا وذهب لانه
كان في زياره الى المستشفى وترك قرار
النشر الى المسؤولين في الوكاله
المراسلات تشير ايضا الى ان المسؤولين في
الوكاله طلبوا من المراسل التحقق من مصدر
اخر ولكن تصاعد الاخبار من بولندا بالسقوط
صواريخ في بولندا يبدو انه مندفعوا الى
اتخاذ قرار بس الخبر خلال عشر دقائق فقط
بذلك الشخص نحو تحقيق سبق صحفي طه على حس
المسؤوليه الصحفيه هذه المره بالنسبه الى
وكاله الانباء والتي يبدو انها ستعاقب ليس
فقط المراسل بالرؤوسا اخرى ستسقط بفعل هذه
الازمه في هذه المؤسسه العريقه
والان الى اخبار الاعلام السريعه
ضاعت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه واوروبيه
الولايات المتحده لانهاء
اثار
قالت في رساله مفتوحه اننا لائحه الاتهام
هذه السابقه خطيره تهدد بتقويه حريه الصحه
اكبر المشتركين
نسب المشاهده لشهر نوفمبر 2022 اظهرت بقاء
فوكس نيوز في صداره المتابعين
56 في المئه من جميع القنوات الاخباريه في
اوقات الذروه هذا فيما شاهدت سي ان
ارتفاعا في نسب المشاهده يذكر ان السي ان
ان شهدت مجموعه من التغييرات فقط التحريري
يبدو انها نجحت في استقدام جماهير اضافيه
قبول شكرا
[موسيقى]